today on the matt walsh show some in the
news media are claiming that the gabby
petito case is only getting all this
attention because she's a white woman
they say that black men and women who
are killed or go missing are often
ignored and they're actually right about
that but not for the reason they think
we'll discuss the real reason today
behind this uh disparity also kamela
harris condemns border patrol agents for
using whips on haitian immigrants even
though border patrol agents did not use
whips on haitian immigrants and bts
performs for the u.n general assembly
providing yet another reason to abolish
the u.n plus 500 female sports stars
come out in support of abortion rights i
didn't even know there were 500 female
sports stars in our daily cancellation
we'll deal with the increasing trend of
teachers coming out to their students
during class all of that and more today
on the matt walsh show
[Music]
one of the best and most effective
things that we can all do um in this uh
present culture war and this fight for
the culture is to find companies that um
support our values and support them
and that's what charity mobile is all
about charity mobile is the pro-life
phone company because five percent of
your monthly plan price goes to the
pro-life pro family charity of your
choice
when you join charity mobile you're
joining a company that's not going to
cancel or censor you for your beliefs in
fact they support and share your beliefs
other mobile service providers are
neutral at best when it comes to the
causes you care about and neutral is
really the best you can hope for most of
them are actively opposed to you but
charity mobile partners with you to
automatically support charities um uh
pro family profile pro family pro-life
charities of your choice charity mobile
makes it easy to switch also you can
keep your existing phone number and you
may even be able to keep your existing
phone you also get excellent coverage
with nationwide service on america's
most reliable network 5g phones are also
available if you do want to switch your
phone so there's nothing to lose here
you got to switch to charity mobile and
support a company and causes that you
care about call them at
1-877-474-3662 or chat with them online
at charitymobile.com
and mention offer code walsh you know
i've never paid much attention to
high-profile murder cases around 40
people are murdered in this country
every single day all of these are sad
situations some sadder than others
perhaps but the media wants us to be
especially concerned
about certain cases and not others i
don't feel obligated to follow their
lead on that point or on any other point
frankly
that's why i haven't followed the gabby
potato case very closely horrible though
it is and for those who have been
similarly out of the loop just a quick
summary potito and her fiance brian
laundry set out on a cross-country road
trip back in early july they
documented their adventures on instagram
and youtube
petito made her last instagram post on
august 25th a week later laundry
returned home alone with no explanation
as to gabby's whereabouts several days
after that he went missing as well he
was possibly captured on a deer camera
footage earlier this week trekking
through the woods of northwest florida
meanwhile the body recovered in a
wyoming national park a few days ago has
now been officially identified as gabby
petito her death has been ruled a
homicide unsurprisingly
why has this case made national
headlines while other missing persons
and murder victims are relegated to the
local news if they get any coverage at
all
it's not very hard to just discern an
answer to that
gabby potato already had a base of
followers on social media who were
interested in her life it makes sense
that they would be likewise interested
in the circumstances of her death she
was young attractive photogenic
the disappearance out in the wilderness
the fiance on the run the additional
details emerging like puzzle pieces
all of these factors make for a more
sensational story
they don't make her death more terrible
than anybody else's death they didn't
make her life more valuable or it's
taking more tragic but they do add up to
a compelling narrative
and it may sound crude to refer to a
real-life murder case in that way as a
compelling narrative and it is
but this is how it works in a society
where people consume
murder cases as entertainment
i mean true crime quote unquote is one
of the most popular genres on every
streaming service for a reason
even if in most cases it's only
partially true what you get in those
documentaries
if true at all
and this is part of the reason why the
national media selects and amplifies
certain murders and not others
though recently prominent members of the
national media itself have pointed to a
different explanation joy reid of msnbc
echoed the claims made by many on the
left when she pegged the gabby potito
coverage as another instance of quote
unquote missing white woman syndrome
reed having never encountered a story
that she won't racialize argues that the
media and the public only care about
white people white women specifically
who go missing or turn up dead
she charges the media with quote
ignoring cases involving missing people
of color let's listen to her
but the way this story has captivated
the nation has many wondering why not
the same media attention when people of
color go missing well the answer
actually has a name missing white woman
syndrome the term coined by the late and
great gwen ifill to describe the media
and public fascination with missing
white women like lacey peterson or
natalie holloway while ignoring cases
involving missing people of color we
have been sounding the alarm for nearly
14 years because of this when it comes
to missing persons of color
men women and children our cases are not
taken seriously and no one is looking
for us if we were to go missing
now if we're going this route
i could just as easily chalk it up to
sexism
when's the last time that a missing or
dead white man made the national
headlines
and if uh anti-black racism lies at the
heart of this
then why do white female alleged
murderers tend to captivate the public
even more than the murder victims
casey anthony jodi arias amanda knox
i can't name a single black female
murderer off the top of my head
is it anti-black racism that leads us to
heap extra scrutiny on white murder
suspects
and yet still the basic observation made
by joy reid and others
cannot be denied black people are killed
or go missing every day
at a rate much higher than whites
actually and none of them unless they're
killed by a cop
we'll go back to that in a second become
household names
here's a concrete example to illuminate
the point
two years ago i talked about this on my
show i've talked about it several times
so you might know about if you listen to
this show but you won't know about this
case if you if you trust the mainstream
media for your news coverage
two years ago a black woman named
brittany hill was shot and killed by
chicago gang members in broad daylight
while holding her one-year-old daughter
in her arms
the footage captured by security cameras
is
haunting
on the surface the crime seems to
contain all of the elements that would
it would attract widespread media
coverage
you have a young woman shot dead in the
street the crime is caught on camera
she dies while laying on top of her
child to shield her from the bullets
it's a devastating story and a dramatic
story
there are many such stories in chicago
and other cities around the country but
this one is on film and even in a place
like chicago it's not every day that a
young woman is executed in the middle of
the afternoon while holding a baby in
her arms
so so why didn't the national media show
any interest in that event
why didn't joy reed ever mention britney
hill's name
the very media that condemns us for
allegedly ignoring black deaths
is itself guilty of ignoring those same
deaths indeed it's entirely their fault
that the deaths are ignored
they're the ones who are supposed to be
calling attention to to to news stories
that's their whole job and they're not
doing it
joy reid has her own show on msnbc a
national platform
she could have single-handedly made
britney hill a household name
and yet she ignored her death entirely
how can that be explained
and don't tell me she didn't hear about
it i mean i heard about it
i'm not in the mainstream media and i
heard about it
and i talked about it
why didn't she
so how do you explain this
i think it's easily explained
the national media disregarded britney
hill because hill was murdered by black
men
the vast majority of black female and
black male murder victims are killed by
black men
that's why joy reid and her ilk ignore
them even as they accuse everyone else
of ignoring them
they don't want to discuss those deaths
because they don't want to talk about
the perpetrators who caused the deaths
as it turns out there are two major
factors deciding whether a murder case
will appear in national headlines the
identity of the victim matters
but so does the identity of the alleged
killer
to pass the media litmus test the case
must be sensational or easily
sensationalized
and it must also be politically useful
a white woman murdered by a white man
fits that bill
that fits both qualifications
potentially
so does a black man or woman killed by
police that's why those names become
household names
well yeah we we don't have there there
are no household names that come to mind
of a black man or woman
killed by another black civilian
but we can all name
several black people have been killed by
cops
can you name any white people who have
been killed by cops off the top of your
head again if you listen to the show
maybe you can but if you rely on
mainstream media you wouldn't be able to
and what explains that again because
it's politically convenient it's all
about the perpetrator
but a black person killed by a black
person who's a civilian certainly fails
to meet this criteria and so does a
white man killed by anyone of any
identity group
i mean what there there are
circumstances where a dead white woman
can become a household name there are
circumstances where a
uh a dead black person becomes a
household name there's almost almost no
circumstance where a dead white guy
becomes a household name it doesn't
matter how he dies
we're not hearing about it
now rare exceptions can be made to that
final rule every once in a while a dead
white man might provide political
fighter to the left even if they have to
lie about the circumstances surrounding
his death see brian sicknick for an
example
and of course none of this applies to
the dead white men who make the
headlines because the media wants to
mock their deaths like the various white
conservative radio hosts who have
succumbed to
but the common thread tying all of this
together
and making sense of all of it
is the media's steadfast refusal to
bring attention to anything that may
conflict or at least fails to advance
their ideological agenda
if it bleeds it leads right that used to
be the motto
we could only long for those cynical yet
still simpler times now nowadays
it might bleed you know if if it bleeds
it might
lead or it might be locked in a vault
and buried under the earth it all
depends on who is doing the bleeding
and who's responsible for spilling the
blood
and how it all gels with the political
narrative
so joy reid is right to call out the
media for how it handles these cases
her mistake was in exempting herself
from that criticism
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
this episode today is brought to you by
the jordan harbinger show you want a new
podcast to add to your rotation you're
sick of all these boring rambling
podcasts like the one you're listening
to right now you one that's you want one
that's entertaining informative and also
packed with actionable content well
don't listen to this show listen to the
jordan harbinger show the jordan
harbinger show is a top shelf podcast
named best of apple in 2018
i didn't win best of apple in 2018 and
i'm not going to win in 2021 i'll tell
you that right now jordan harbinger he
did so don't just ignore my suggestion
to listen to this one like you probably
do with your other friends who tell you
to listen to podcasts
no you got to check out this show jordan
dives into the minds of fascinating
people from athletes authors and
scientists to ceos political activists
and government officials
i really think there just isn't a better
podcast to listen to casually or
seriously to expand your worldview
i mean again there's not a better part
certainly this is not the better podcast
to listen to point blank jordan
harbinger is smart funny and easy to
listen to
so turn this garbage off and turn to
jordan harbinger right now you can't go
wrong with adding the jordan harbinger
show to your rotation it's incredibly
interesting there is never a doll show
so search for the jordan harbinger show
that's h-a-r-b-i-n-g-e-r
on apple podcast spotify or wherever you
listen to podcasts yeah one thing i
always uh i'm always telling parents
especially if you're a young parent just
had kids
one of the best things you can do as
your kid gets older is um
is
you know incorporate them into the
things that you like to do especially as
especially dads this is especially
important because that's what the kids
really want you know you don't have to
as as
these days we have this idea that you
got to go out and do these sort of these
child-centric activities all the time
in order to entertain the kids but what
the kids really want is they want to be
involved in your life they want to do
the things that you're interested in
doing
and um the great thing about that
strategy as a parent is that it also
just
it can be it's it's good for the kid but
it can also be a little bit self-serving
so it's
it's
the best of both worlds
and so uh yesterday my my son told me
that uh because i haven't you know one
thing i like to do is go fishing i've
incorporated him i've incorporated all
the kids in that
and so now he's at a point where he'll
ask me to go and so yesterday he said he
really wants to go fishing on saturday
and so i had i told my wife like
this is what i got to do on saturday i
got to take the kid fishing because it's
father this is what he wants to do it's
father-son time
it's my responsibility now to spend the
day fishing with him
it's not about what i want to do
this is this is about this is about the
the child
and she had no choice but to agree so
that's the great part about that
all right so kamala harris has emerged
from hiding emerged from the bed that
she's been hiding under
ever since uh afghanistan
or the bed she's been hiding in we're
doing whatever she's doing in the bed
you never know with her but the point is
she's out in front of cameras now to
condem border patrol agents for doing
their job let's listen to that
what i saw depicted about um those
individuals on horseback
treating human beings the way they were
is horrible
and i fully support what is happening
right now which is a thorough
investigation into exactly what is going
on there
um but human beings should never be
treated that way
and i'm deeply troubled about it the
whole point is that we have to
understand haiti i mean talk about a
country that has just experienced so
much
uh tragedy that has been about natural
disasters the the head of state
assassinated and we really have to do a
lot more to recognize that as a member
of the western hemisphere
we've got to support some very basic
needs that the people of haiti have
to get back up
these people are so
evil and the the only solace we could
take is that they're all evil but also
stupid and incompetent that's the one
thing that saves us
thank god
you know
thank god they all have double-digit iqs
at best
there's no evil and brilliant person
that's when we're really in trouble
this is just a bad person you heard from
there
because she knows better now i'll say
kamala harris
probably an authority on the subject of
whips
so
on on
on one hand you might say that there's a
reason for her to chime in on this
subject
but uh she knows
she absolutely knows
that this whole whip narrative is
completely fabricated it didn't happen
have you wondered why if you've watched
the coverage of this
you haven't actually seen a video of any
haitian immigrant being whipped
that's that's not on tape anywhere
because it didn't happen
because those were horse rains that they
were using
and now they've actually retreated a
little bit you find now that the um
the narrative on social media at least
has has retreated a bit and they've
moved the goal posts
and now what you're hearing is
well it might not have been a whip
exactly but it was a it was a horse
rings that were being used in a
whip-like way
in in an intimidating way
because there is one there's there's one
clip of a
one of the border patrol agents on
horseback kind of twirling the rope
around very quickly
uh which is pretty clear he's doing that
to kind of lash the horse to get the
horse to move
but it didn't make contact with anybody
with any human being
and so now rather than whipping and
lassoing haitian immigrants not at the
border which was the original thing we
were told
uh now it's they they were using it an
intimidating way
it was scary the way that they were
moving the rope was scary
hey i say all this we talked about it
yesterday but the truth is
i wouldn't
mind if border patrol agents were at the
border on horseback using lassos
on people who are trying to sneak across
the border i mean
that wouldn't bother me that much
but that's actually not not what's
happening at all and she knows that
and these are the people that work for
her i mean not for her directly they
work for the administration
and they are
ready to throw them right under the bus
send them down there to do a job an
almost impossible job
and then when they attempt to do the job
and uh they end up on video and people
are mad about it throw them right under
the bus
destroy their life doesn't matter
because these people are souls i mean
kamela harris is totally soulless
and we haven't even talked about the
second part of her little statement
there where she says that we have a
responsibility to the people of haiti do
we
why do we have a special responsibility
to haiti
can you explain that one
and why why are we the ones with the
unique responsibility
there are many other countries in this
hemisphere
do they have no responsibility why is it
always us
why does it always fall to us
and and the thing is people like camille
harris people on the left they have no
response to that question
because the only response you come up
with is that uh
is that you know the united states is
this especially virtuous country where
the right the city the shining city on
the hill and all that kind of stuff
um
if you're going to claim that we have a
special responsibility
to every country in the world especially
ones that we share a hemisphere with
then the only reason you could really
give
is that we're a special country and we
we are especially charitable and
virtuous
and that's where the responsibility
comes from
and maybe those other countries
you know we can't really expect them to
step up to the plate
because those people aren't as generous
as us
if you're going to make that argument
then go ahead and make it
except that camilla harris would also
tell us that that's not what she thinks
about america
she thinks america's
a racist
dystopian hellscape and it is
increasingly dystopian but
because she's
one of the people in charge of it
so they're they're
their narrative doesn't really make any
sense
uh unless i guess the other way you
could go is go to the other extreme and
you say that um
well we have a special responsibility to
all these other countries
because it's somehow our fault
the fact that haiti is in the shape that
it's in all these other countries that
are suffering and all the people that
are suffering somehow it's all our fault
and so that's why we have to bring we
have to open our arms and accept them i
guess that's what they would go with
but the other problem as we discussed
yesterday is that she's talking about
this
um as if all of these people who are in
del r all of these haitians who are in
del rio right now uh as if they they
they came from haiti they were fleeing
from haiti
from
economic and political disaster
and getting on boats by the thousands
and sailing up the gulf of mexico
docking on the shores of mexico and then
traveling across the desert west for
some reason and then trying to enter
through del rio which is not what's
happening at all
i don't know exactly what's happening i
i can't tell you exactly why
there are 10 to 12 000
haitians building a tent city in del rio
right now
i can't tell you because
no one's asking the question no one
who's in a position to have the question
answered is asking it
but what is very clear at a minimum
is that they're they're not coming
directly from haiti okay they're coming
from haiti by way of central america
where where they've probably been for
years
and where they can stay
there's the reason why they have to come
here
if they needed asylum from haiti they
already got it
if they're moving again
they're not asylum seekers they're not
refugees anymore
they're just illegal immigrants
all right the un general assembly is in
progress
and um my guys bts my boys
my favorite band they they uh
they were at the un general assembly
for some reason
and uh they they played one of their
songs
in the halls of the un
building and they also spoke to the
assembled nations about vaccines
probably i haven't even watched the clip
but let's let's watch some of this
[Music]
[Applause]
some of you heard the news that we're
coming to the un and a lot of you were
wondering whether we have been
vaccinated and i'll take this
opportunity to say yes all seven of us
of course we received vaccinations
[Music]
all right
sir's bts for you
[Music]
oh they're still dancing
oh just awful just awful
uh and they were at the u.n this this
goes back this is i could think of a no
better argument for abolishing the u.n
than that
if
with everything happening in the world
right now all of the crises that the un
allegedly would be
interested in trying to solve
and yet and yet they have time for a
musical performance from a boy band i
mean just think about this for a second
they tell us we're in the middle of a
global pandemic there's a crisis in
afghanistan and everyone else
and uh and
let's take a pause and and
for a musical interlude from bts
making time for that
i just need to get rid of the un
it has served
no good function
certainly for for many many years
all right from uh the daily wire it says
on monday over 500 women including u.s
women's soccer player megan rappino and
hundreds of professional athletes
olympians and college athletes called on
the supreme court to strike down a
mississippi law
that would ban abortions after 15 weeks
in most circumstances
their actions come as the supreme court
set a december date to hear the case
the women wrote in an amicus brief we
believe that like themselves the next
generation of women athletes must be
guaranteed bodily integrity and
decisional autonomy in order to fully
and equally participate in sports
wnba players diana taurasi and sue bird
whose rapido's fiance are two of the
women's athletes that are part of the
brief brief
the the group argues that abortion is a
major factor in the enormous success of
women's sports
and that women's participation in sports
would be severely impaired if the right
to access abortion is restricted well
just as there was no better argument for
abolishing the un and the fact that bts
is performing there
uh maybe no better argument for
abolishing women's sports and the fact
that it's its success can be attributed
to abortion
according to these female athletes if
what they're saying is true
i don't think it is but that's their
claim
where to even start with this
first of all
you see again how these outside forces
are involving themselves and something
that has nothing to do with them
megan rappino does she live in uh
mississippi
maybe she does but i don't know where
she was i somehow i doubt it
certainly i doubt that all 500 of these
female professional athletes live in
mississippi
so
they're involving themselves
in this uh in this issue in in
mississippi that does not directly
affect them
and of course the left
embraces that in that case
but on the right
you know we are having
for example we're having our uh
our rally on september 28th the la at
the loudoun county school board meeting
which you're all invited to attend in
ashburn uh virginia
about you know to to protest their
radical pro-trans policies that that are
among other things a direct assault on
women's uh on on girls sports there
because they're gonna allow boys into
girls sports
but as i've been talking about this
rally and encouraging people to attend
i've been told
by the left that uh this doesn't concern
me i'm an outside agitator what it's not
my business to be involved in this
what am i doing there this is about this
is louden county this is virginia
in fact i was told that
showing up at a school board meeting
meeting at my local school board here in
nashville
when i gave my two cents on the mass
mandate and they said that doesn't
concern you either you're an outsider
because you don't send your kids a
public school
even though my money helps to support
the public schools
in nashville and in fact across the
entire country through the uh department
of education that i helped fund as does
everybody else
very much against our will
so that is outside agitation that is a a
case of you know you need to mind your
own business
and yet at the professional athletes who
do not live in mississippi can involve
themselves file an amicus brief with the
supreme court
to try to control legislation in
mississippi so you see how that works
and they've done the same thing in texas
i mean they do they do the same thing
anytime any state or locality passes a
law or an ordinance or a policy that
they don't like
but
they they see abortion as a direct
attack
on women's sports
and i guarantee you if you were to ask
these people
how they feel about men
being involved in women's sports and
women in the the doors of women's sports
being open to men who call themselves
women
they don't think that's an attack on
women's sports but abortion is somehow
this as always uh is
you know the exact opposite of inspiring
and motivational
for women
because once again women are being told
that if you want to succeed in life in
this case if you want to succeed as an
athlete
you need to have the ability to kill
your child
it's it's not going to be possible to
pursue your dreams
if you do
if you fully embrace your womanhood
and your femininity
and the full power of being a woman and
one of the most profound powers that a
woman has is to bring children into the
world
what we hear from these feminists
is that in order for a woman to
fully be herself
and be successful in this world she has
to reject
violently reject that part of herself
i mean think about that that uh that
power that miraculous ability
that both men and women
play a part in
the ability to create another person
but for women and only women
they have the unique ability to bear
that child within themselves and bring
the child into the world
you are not supporting women
unless you're supporting women in that
capacity
and encouraging them in that capacity
telling them to reject it reject it even
by spilling the blood of their own
children that is not supporting women
all right next we have um this is
something that's been making the rounds
online and then it ended up on msnbc and
also the daily show
it's footage from a news segment from
the
1980s and why are we
talking about a new segment okay this is
from nbc nightly news in 1984. why are
we talking about a news segment from nbc
nightly news 1984
well because
uh
it's it's footage about a new seatbelt
law that went into effect at the time
and the left loves this segment now
because they think it makes some kind of
point about vaccine mandates so first
let's uh let's watch the second
it is a new seat belt ordinance if the
town council gets its way seat belts
will be mandatory for everybody riding
in the front seat of a car through
richland i'll have to detour the town to
get to kalamazoo they pass a seat belt
or just but i don't use a seat belt i
wouldn't wear my seatbelt if i
get caught i get caught i guess florida
highway patrol lieutenant chris miller
hears it all when it comes to seat belts
i hear it's uncomfortable
it wrinkles my clothes it's not cool
there's no freedom no more
you don't want to wear it that's your
choice
okay so
um
the obvious point the reason that why
this was played on msnbc the daily show
is supposed to be that people the people
in this clip are you know the ones
objecting to seat belt laws are a bunch
of dumb rubes
and uh just like the dumb rubes who
object to mask and vaccine mandates
that's the comparison being made
now just so happens
that uh i i actually sitting here in
2021 i agree with them in 1984
about and and the year the date of that
news report is
is
interesting as well but i agree with
them on seat belt laws i i actually
don't support seat belt laws
um
not because i don't support seat belts i
wear my seat belt every time i get the
car i tell my kids to wear seat belt
i just don't think we need
police officers to be concerned with
that we don't need police officers
there's a lot of crime that they could
be chasing down having them sit on the
side of the highway or the side of the
road looking for people so they can
scold people for not wearing a seat belt
i think that's a waste of law
enforcement resources
i don't think i don't think that's an
issue for law enforcement to concern
itself with that's my problem with seat
belt laws and also with seat belts
if you don't wear your seatbelt you are
only
putting your own health in jeopardy
you're not you're not endangering
anybody else
um
so i don't i don't like seat belt laws
as it is i fully admit that
i think mainly they function as
just like many other traffic laws and
the way they're enforced they function
as fundraising mechanisms for the state
that's mostly what they're about
but
why are we talking about seat belt seat
belts i mean we've been told
that the comparison between auto
accidents and covid is invalid
i have drawn this sort of comparison
many times in the past
many others have drawn it
and we've always been told well those
are two different things you can't you
can't make that comparison
automobile accidents aren't contagious
for one thing it's not a contagious
virus it's a completely different thing
now apparently it's valid again
okay so
if they're raising the subject
then here's a question
um
how does this this this is all about
risk assessment
really
i think that's the real comparison we
can make
because seat belts
and airbags together
if you if you
both of those uh
both both of those precautions if you
take both of those precautions and most
people driving in modern cars today you
got the seat belts and you have the
airbags
that reduces your risk of fatality
by only 60
which is better than zero percent i mean
it's a good reason to have the airbags
and the seatbelt
but it's only a 60 reduction
they're not as effective as most people
probably think
so you reduce your risk of fatality by
60 when you've got around 60 when you've
got airbags and seat belts
but you also when you get into the car
and you drive down the road
um
you know there's a there's a chance that
you could get into a fatal accident even
with those precautions and
and and die but also you don't know if
if you hit somebody else
you don't know if they have their seat
belt on you don't know if they have
airbags or not
so you could you could take precautions
for yourself but you don't know about
anybody else in any of those other
cars know when you get on the road
especially when you get on the highway
you're putting your own life in jeopardy
you are
and you're also putting other people's
lives in jeopardy
go
flying down the road in a in a tin
bucket at 75 miles an hour
if you accidentally hit somebody else
you kill them no matter if they have the
seat belt or not
and so there is this
real risk that you take
you put your kids in the car and you
have them in the uh in even if you have
them in the modern car seats and
everything that are like things out of a
space shuttle with the way uh with how
bulky they are and all that you got the
five-point harness and everything else
and you could take all those precautions
but there's still a chance that your
kids could be killed in the car
a relatively small chance
but not not vanishingly small
it happens to tens of thousands of
people every single year so you put your
kids in the car and you drive down the
road there's a chance that you could
kill your kids accidentally in the car
or somebody else could
and of all the the safety precautions
that you could take it's only going to
reduce your risk of death by 60
so with the way here's the point with
the way that we talk about masks and
vaccines and cover precautions
and considering you could only reduce
your risk of death by 60 percent
even with all these precautions
it would seem like the people who you
know won't walk down the road
walk down the street without a mask on
even when they're vaccinated
you know won't walk through a grocery
store without a mask on even when
they're vaccinated
for them the risk of of contracting
covet very very low the the risk of
getting severely sick from it very very
very low
and yet they're not willing to take that
risk
considering you're not willing to take
that risk in the grocery store walking
on the street why are you willing to
take the risk in the car
with the way you're calculating risk and
the way that you're performing these
risk assessments what you should be
doing
is just not driving at all
that that's the way you really prevent
yourself from being killed in the cars
just by not driving
or at the very least drastically
drastically reducing the amount of time
you spend in the car
but you don't do that
you don't even think about it
you get in the car you drive down the
street and unless the weather is really
bad or there's something that's made you
especially cognizant of the risks
involved most of the time you don't even
you don't perform any risk calculation
at all you just get in the car and you
drive
you never say to yourself when you get
in the car well
here's where i'm going
the risk of death is this
this place that i want to go is it
really worth that risk you don't perform
that kind of calculation you just get in
the car and you drive
that's where the real disconnect is
if you're too afraid to walk into
walmart without a mask on
if that minimal risk of death very
minimal to you especially if you're a
vaccinated person or if you have natural
immunity if that is too great
then the risk of death in a car should
certainly also be too great for you
all right let's get now to uh reading
the youtube comments
who's rocking polka dot and flannel
shirts without shame
do you know their name
they're the sweet baby gang
great all right let's get uh okay this
is from not important says quoting me
says you can kill seven kids and not get
fired from a government government job
matt i don't know what you expected from
a government that funds abortion yeah i
realized that yesterday after i made
that claim that uh government is the
only
the only place where you can kill
children in your you know in your job
you can make you can make a mistake that
kills children
like the seven kids who were killed by a
drone in afghanistan a couple weeks ago
the only place where you can do that and
still keep your job and it occurred to
me after the fact that well there is
there's one major exception to that and
that is the abortion industry i mean if
you're an abortionist you kill kids
every single day and not only do you
keep your job but you get uh you're
you're commended and celebrated for it
um
vroodon the great says something that's
been lost childhood matt please keep
them away from this toxic sewer for as
long as possible this is a genie you
can't put back in the bottle i commend
you for being a good father
unfortunately
your kids are in the minority
yeah and that's that's the key for as
long as possible and when you say toxic
sewer i assume you mean the internet
you can't keep your kids away from it
forever that's true
um
eventually unless you really do move out
into the woods and go completely off the
grid and decide to live that way i think
there's something to be said for that
for that mode of living if that's what
you want to do but if you're not going
to that extreme and we certainly haven't
then they're going to be exposed to the
internet eventually but um
but the longer you wait the better is
the way i look at it
and you're you should be equipping them
with the psychological and emotional and
spiritual tools that they're going to
need
once they are
[Music]
faced with all this filth out in society
and on the internet and everything else
but first you have to you have to build
them up you have to prepare them for
that
a lot of parents today they just sort of
throw their kids in
you know throw them into the deep end
without teaching them how to swim first
you just throw them in and hope that
they figure it out
some kids do but um but most kids won't
uh let's see another really really
stupid argument that i've heard when i
was you know talking yesterday about
insulating your kids from some of this
technology and and not letting this
technology dominate their lives and
don't give your kid a smartphone with
internet access
one argument i hear in response to that
one criticism is that well your kids are
gonna get left behind because all the
other kids are gonna learn how to use
this technology
and your kids won't
i find that to be a really silly
argument because for one thing
your kids are not using the technology
the technology is using them
you know a child who's
on their phone
17 hours a day
or at least on some kind of screen 17
hours a day can't look up from it can't
spend more than two minutes without
without going back to it
that's not a child who has command over
these devices these devices have command
over him
and there are a lot of adults who are in
that same boat
but also kids take to this stuff
very easily
you don't need to learn you don't need
to teach your six-year-old how to use a
phone so that they know how to do it
when they're adults
kids at any age figure this stuff out
really quick
i mean my my uh
my eight-year-old daughter doesn't have
a phone doesn't spend any time on a
phone
but the other day i saw her she picked
up my phone
and uh put put it on the camera and like
took a picture
she was able to figure figure it out
that quickly
so kids take to this stuff you don't
need to expose it to it that early in
order for them to do it amy says
i want an spg t-shirt but that one is
creepy
matt is not the baby in the gang the
shirt makes no sense
it makes matt look like he has some
weird diaper fetish no thanks
amy did you think that you could
come into our comment section
and insult me and and the whole gang
that way
i'm not saying that your criticism is
wrong you're actually completely right
but that doesn't make it hurt any less
and you're banned from the show how dare
you
uh en says matt it's pronounced gen saki
the p is silent man
well we will agree to disagree on that
one i suppose josh says man screw you
matt the quiet place was great
yeah the quiet place was a very good
movie
um
the fact that we now have to qualify it
is it as a great film and i think in
comparison to many other movies that
have been made over the last 10 15 years
maybe it does qualify as great but that
just shows you the how the standards
have dropped i think it's a it's a good
movie
but if there were if there were real
great films being made i don't think we
would be calling the quiet place one of
them it's a it's just it's a good
effective movie
uh finally charlie said or carly rather
sorry i misgendered you there matt i
know you think all stories about kids
saying profound things are made up
but this one is absolutely true my
second grade son asked me to buy him a
sweet baby gang shirt so that he could
wear it to school and everyone would be
confused
we're clearly raising him right
well you certainly are and uh i don't
even i don't know if we make do we make
the shirts and child sizes i'm not sure
but that doesn't matter
congratulations to maybe the youngest
member of the sweet baby gang now a word
from relief band you guys know i am a
big fan of relief band i don't go
anywhere without without my trusty
relief band because a relief band is the
number one fda cleared anti-nausea
wristband that's been clinically proven
to quickly relieve and effectively
prevent nausea and vomiting associated
with anxiety migraine hangover morning
sickness chemotherapy and also motion
sickness which is my special plight my
cross that i that i bear the product is
100
drug free it's non-drowsy and provides
all natural relief with zero side
effects for as long as needed the
technology was originally developed over
20 years ago in hospitals to help
relieve nausea from patients but now the
relief band it is available to the
masses how it works is relief band
stimulates a nerve in the wrist that
travels to the part of the brain that
controls nausea and then it blocks the
signal your brain is sending to your
stomach telling you that you're sick
sounds complicated but as far as you're
concerned just put the relief band on
and you'll feel better so it's really
that simple ensure that nausea is never
the reason to miss out on life's
important moments right now relief band
has an exclusive exclusive offer just
for matt walsh listeners if you go to
reliefband.com and use promo code walsh
you'll receive 20 off plus free shipping
and no questions asked 30-day money-back
guarantee so head to
r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-n-d dot com and use
promo code walsh for 20 off and also the
events of the past few weeks have been
troubling to say the least the buy
administration continues to treat their
own citizens like criminals using
divisive phrases like the pandemic of
the unvaccinated to sow division and
bully americans into accepting their
tyrannical new vaccine mandate which
requires that any business with over 100
employees
has to force mandatory vaccinations or
weekly testing for covet and that
includes the daily wire but as you know
we are fighting back against that and
facing potentially 14 000 per violation
so um
if you want to help us in this fight the
best thing you can do is go to
dailywire.com subscribe and use code do
not comply at checkout for 25 off
americans have been far too willing to
cede their freedoms to authoritarian
bureaucrats in the name of public health
enough is enough so please stand with us
at the daily wire and most importantly
the rights of all american citizens
god bless america now let's get to our
daily cancellation
[Music]
one of the major reasons why nothing
works in this country and all of our
institutions are collapsing is that very
few people especially those running
those institutions are capable of seeing
beyond themselves they don't care about
anything greater than themselves they
don't recognize that anything greater
than themselves can even exist they
certainly aren't focused on the larger
mission of the institution but instead
are totally enveloped in their own egos
this intense self-focus destroys every
institution down to the smallest and
most essential one like the family
the institution can't survive if
everybody within that institution
everybody is in charge of leading it
spends all day staring at their own
reflections
somebody needs to be focused on the
grander broader vision somebody needs to
take the long view
a view in which they are not the central
figure
but few people these days are capable of
that
there's a term that's become popular on
social media called main character
syndrome this describes people who
imagine themselves to be the protagonist
the leads
and their lives to be some sort of
cinematic feature film in in which they
are the star
you could really just use the term
narcissist here because it has basically
the same meaning except that main
character syndrome is helpful because it
captures the way that so many people
today tend to not only place themselves
at the center of the universe but also
fictionalize the universe at the same
time
they're the main characters in the story
of their lives but that story has only a
tangential relationship to the truth
i mean it's sort of based on true events
at best
we could take this main character
phenomenon and relate it back to the
collapse of our societal institutions
and there's probably no institution
that suffers more from this problem than
the education system
the problem in education today well one
of the many one of the great many
problems
it's not just that so many teachers are
intensely ideological
but that they're also intensely
self-centered
which leads them to believe that it can
never be inappropriate
for them to indoctrinate their students
after all the class they're teaching is
really all about them everything's about
them they are the subject
they've been hired to teach history or
algebra or english literature or
whatever but their real job as far as
they're concerned is to shape the
students into little versions of
themselves
and all of this explains the recent
trend
of teachers coming out coming out to
their students during class
i've seen at least three videos
documenting this in just the last few
weeks we played one several days ago
where a high school teacher records
himself in class
as he called the students attention to
himself and proceeded to inform them
that he is non-binary and his preferred
pronouns are all pronouns he is all
things to all people as the apostle paul
once wrote though in a very different
context we're not going to play that
video again but we do have two more
first here's another non-binary teacher
talking about her experiences coming out
to her students
and she's talking about them in response
to a question from another teacher who
is also non-binary and here's what she
says you can be reasonably assured that
you are safe being out on your campus um
then do it
before coming out as non-binary um i
would come out to my students um every
october on national coming out day i
would use that as an opportunity for my
students to learn how to receive
somebody coming out to them in case that
had never happened to them before um we
used it as a way to talk to each other
about empathy about connection about
trust it ended up being a wonderful
experience that i had with my students
every single year so think about what
you would have needed when you were in
high school or middle school or whatever
grade you're teaching for some students
just the knowledge that a queer adult
exists within their their world is
hugely impactful you don't really have
to do anything other than be visible for
these students to feel safer and more
accepted and more at home when they're
on campus it it does so much for
students who don't have that in other
places in their lives for that reason my
classroom is one of the gayest places
probably on the planet everything is
completely covered in rainbows i've got
flags everywhere i've got queer
literature because i want every student
that i have to know that being queer is
something that i am proud of something
that is not um a secret in my life it's
something that i care about and
something that connects me to other
people i'll end by saying that for me
being visibly queer is a non-negotiable
i introduced myself this year with my
pronouns immediately it was the one of
the first things that students learned
about me
you know somehow the most irritating
part of that was still the word
impactful
just an awful word but that's beside the
point the point is that this
pathologically self-absorbed narcissist
enjoys the attention and
self-congratulation of coming out so
much that she does it every year
she has by her own admission turned her
entire classroom into a temple to
herself
the only thing that's missing is like
the uh incense and the the hooded monks
chanting in an ancient language
as is this religious temple of
self-worship every day in her classroom
it is a chance for all of her students
to join her in worshiping herself it is
a celebration of her own sexual
proclivities
and she doesn't feel weird about
inviting kids to take part in that
celebration or forcing them to in fact
because this is her we're talking about
and what could be more important what
subject could be more pressing
than the subject of herself
that was also the approach of the
teacher in the next clip who recorded a
video
sharing her thoughts after having just
come out to her sixth grade students
it was important that the sixth graders
be told you know who she likes to sleep
with
um they really needed to know that
information about their teacher's sexual
behavior so she was sure to inform them
so i
just came out to my students
[Music]
i've been wanting to do this for the
past two years
sorry i'm like so emotional
um and i just haven't had the courage to
do it
out of fear of just judgment mostly from
their parents
but
i had these kids in fourth grade and
now i have them in six and i'm sending
them to middle school and i love these
kids so much and i trust them and they
make me feel safe and i know they love
me and
just felt right and i i did it and
it was so beautiful
[Music]
they had so many questions which i loved
they wanted to learn and they wanted to
learn about me and
they were so eager and
a few of them clapped which was
so precious
so you notice how this was a spontaneous
and emotional video revealing her true
feelings and yet she took the time to
edit
and add the inspirational soundtrack in
the background
i mean it's hard to think of a better
example of main character syndrome than
that notice also how she says that
they make me feel safe that's an adult
woman a teacher referring to the 11 year
olds in her classroom
and she says that um
they wanted to learn about me
and maybe they did
or maybe they felt forced to pretend
that they did but whatever the case do
we send kids to school so so that they
can learn about their teachers
as far as these teachers are concerned
the answer is yes what subject could be
more important than the subject of
themselves and on the subject of
themselves
what could be a more important detail
than their sex lives
see they see themselves as defined by
their sex lives and they see the world
as revolving around themselves which
means that the world revolves around
their sex lives
this uh mentality
makes for dysfunctional people
and with enough of these people in the
education system whatever their sexual
orientation it makes for a dysfunctional
education system
and that is why teachers who come out to
their students
are today certainly and finally
canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens
production manager pablo vadowsky the
show is edited by ali hinkle
our audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by cherokee heart
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matte wall show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 2021
roughly half the country believes that
joe biden is not mentally fit enough to
serve as president a surprise republican
climbs the presidential field and ron
desantis picks the greatest surgeon
general in america anti-mask mandate
anti-vaccine mandate
pro-common sense a really good way to
strike back against the liberal
establishment check it out on the
michael knowles show